Justin Jordan Welch did a heat piece on
the War Room his video was posted one
after Tristan's interview after he
joined in bad faith and was trying to
expose States your thoughts
all right no God Did You Justin I know
I'm comment on it I saw it by the time I
sent it to Luke he was already psyched
there's nothing really to say man so I
found it I was surprised he saw it I
thought he was gonna say he had Nina and
I liked it he's like yeah I'm not even
gonna speak about that [ __ ] you don't
responding to haters and giving it too
much attention if it's not necessary is
pointless it sounds like I should say
does anybody know if there's just this
Jordan Welch guy went into the War Room
did he join and have an experience and
then do a hit piece on it or did he just
[ __ ] all over it from the outside from
his video he joined and you know from
what he saw that's that was his that's
what he said well not everybody's gonna
have a happy experience in any business
I am curious I'd like to see it we can
watch that later yeah matter of fact can
you guys talk about how y'all met and
the importance of networking and how
where everybody got proof of that and I
see people in the chat and I've been
reading um just looking online
chronically I know a lot of you tell me
not to engage in these haters and stuff
like that but it's really opened up my
mind to why people become losers instead
of winners I met Justin at Vendome at
the club
um maybe two weeks ago in Miami I was
going out with fresh and then I met him
so I've I'm a fan of Justin I've seen
his videos
uh appearances on emergency meetings and
one thing I've realized and I want to
say this for the younger people watching
this and the people who are making
excuses and the people who like to say
that it's luck it's really about the
mindset you have and the mentality you
have in order to become a millionaire
that's the number one thing that I've
realized can shift somebody from
becoming a Brokey into a
multi-millionaire is just accepting the
fact that you need to be accountable for
your own actions you need to put
yourself in the right situations you
need to put out the right energy it's
really just a mentality shift and I
think all multi millionaires that I've
met personally I know you guys will
agree with that it's just about how you
switch and where you prioritize your
time and who you surround yourself with
yeah well um we got uh Kratos Rd goes
where do I meet quality people I'm 18
living in Central Florida snico said I
gotta add value to other people so I
took on cutting hair and learning online
bro value and you need to not make
excuses a lot of people spend time
coping on the internet writing
paragraphs writing essays and investing
their energy into next it's the same
thing when people like people have no
networking skills online like the amount
of people that just text me are like bro
we go to hop on a call it's like a
random dude I'm like why would I waste
10 minutes hopping on a call with you
right a random guy it's really up to me
you can't be a crybaby you can't blame
it on other people you can't be jealous
you can't be a hater you are not going
to succeed if you're going to hate if
you're gonna be sad if you're gonna
blame it on something else you would
just won't succeed so it's so true to
decide okay what do I have to do to get
one of those liberals
to add value to the world is to be
around the right people excuses
you will succeed it's really that simple
and I'm proof of that three months ago I
was just watching these videos I was
just watching I watched so many of these
videos in this exact studio and I'm
sitting here in the seat because I
applied myself properly I put out the
correct energy I talk to the right
people and people realize that I added
value to the world it's really that
simple and very good point he has what
do you mean quality people what does it
go do you watch videos took an
information and applied it by applying
that information you'll find some hit
myself in the same room so you know what
you might have to meet him in person but
just being able to take an information
watch the video it might be in person
after so makes sense yeah all the
information but before you continue all
the information that you need in order
to become a multi-millionaire is online
yeah you don't need to go to school it's
not the secret formula it's not a secret
they literally convince you throughout
high school that if you don't get good
grades you're not going to get into a
good college and you're not going to do
a good job that's exactly what they
would drill into your mind for that four
years it's crazy to think look back and
think that that's how my brain was wired
because I was messing up in high school
my life was basically over they taught
you no critical thinking skills or how
that it's even possible to make money on
your own especially without a degree
well I I think that we had we had some
more complicated
right so yes in school they're teaching
you good grades good grades I wanted you
to get good grades because I knew what
your potential was and I wanted you to
you know have options and that's what we
used to talk about we used to talk about
options like if you have shitty grades
and you want to go to college your
options are very limited you know and if
you have shitty grades and you didn't
learn some some important Basics that
are practical in life that limits your
options even outside of college so
that's what we always talked about like
you're closing doors on yourself when
you have potential and you're not using
it so all of this like apply yourself
apply yourself apply yourself because
the thing is also apply while you were
in high school you can't just if there
are high schoolers listening to this you
know that that applies yeah the thing is
so back in high school I was working to
be a professional fortnite player which
is you know I was it wasn't my geek
phase
but I mean I was working at something
like I was really passionate about it
and I really wanted to make a living off
of it and make millions of dollars
I mean it's a different geek phase now
I'm in the red pill just kidding you
know Niche which is funny how last year
I was in the crypto stocks and if
teenage no I keep switching around you
know what I mean but if you're just like
[ __ ] off in high school and you're
like no I know it'll be good then no
like that's that's not what I'm just say
shmout right I just don't even know even
though I was grinding yeah even though I
was grinding fortnite which is cringy
looking back on it it's like yeah I
guess everyone I guess everyone wants to
be a professional Esports player at one
point in their lives yeah I mean it it's
I don't think it's I don't think it's
dorky or geeky because you weren't a kid
who just
anti-social you still played hockey you
still left the house you played
basketball pick up basketball with your
friends all the time you had friends
over we always had a full house like you
weren't just some complete weirdo living
in the basement gotta say what the [ __ ]
is this I wouldn't have had it I
wouldn't had it if you were total freak
geek they wouldn't no my kid wasn't
going to be a weirdo not like super and
I made I made some money on it people
used to like you know everyone was
begging to play with me yeah yeah you
weren't thinking about you were doing
good
yourself up for that don't
I know I just don't want people going
down the video game Rabbit Hole I want
people doing better [ __ ] you know unless
one day you can be pink Tommy if I
stream video games would you guys watch
I mean I'll put a one in chat if you
guys would watch me streaming some some
fortnite back when I was a grinder so
that you need to sign up I will not be
watching it's really just about no
baseball what information learning how
you could become valuable and becoming
different than other people adding
something to the world that nobody else
can add becoming unique and then you
will succeed if you can apply that and
you realize that that's the red pill for
a lot of people is deciding like okay I
need to do something different than
other people I need to understand and
when you do you will succeed ma'am do
you have anything interesting answer
yeah let's just say understand where you
are on the totem pole man like for
example two two things for him you're
not gonna become a millionaire Clinton
here and I'll say that with love so you
need to learn how truth you need to
learn how to own that [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] so if you want to if you make
if you if you cut hair and you make
content out of it and then you're able
to level up your business even more get
a ton of high value clients inside and
then you know how to make those tick
tocks and then you make products and you
exactly which I think is probably where
he's going to go you know what could
Vidal says soon started cutting hair
this is what I teach this like this is
exactly what I'm saying if you run any
business and you're not making short
form content with it you're missing out
and if you don't know how to do it
properly you're just you're shooting
yourself in the foot I'm teaching people
for 30 a month I was I was selling your
reports the other day like you know
trying to convince one of our cousins
the other day to and this is how
versatile it is so to take the course
because he's an expert at Disney world
like freaking you anybody that I know
who goes to Disney I'm like just call
Anthony and he knows all the ins and
outs and how to book your vacation and
their all of it the time yeah oh my God
that would be so hot on on Tech talk
right and he's like just got this like
he's just a likable guy yeah you know
when he's got this jovial way about him
he's like Mr freaking Disney and the
whole family that's the only thing they
go on vacation twice a year always to a
Disney property or Cruise so I was
telling him like you're gonna retire
soon from your day job you could make so
much money online being the Disney guy
and there are Disney guys out there
whereas but there's not you there's a
guy with the Disney guy with the
Brooklyn accent and then he's the and
then and the happy face yeah but if he
makes those videos then he gets like a
cooler job at Disney he works there
everyone recognizes him it just goes
like there's just goes there's so many
and I I he kind of got a little twinkle
in his eye thinking about it you
couldn't name a business to me where I
couldn't tell you short form content
wouldn't help your business grow rapidly
there isn't one business that you could
tell me and even learning how to do it
and helping other people grow they're
getting paid to do it for other
businesses is another way like you know
how do you have to have your own how do
you think only fans people make so much
money well they show their boobies yeah
but they do it through short form
content and they get millions of views
yeah and then it translates so strange
because there's like boobies everywhere
there are boobies everywhere remember
when I ran is that exciting to see new
ones I have a funny story I don't know
if I should say it but do you remember
when I ran your your ex you know your
old client um the comedian's uh Tick
Tock account yeah and he was complaining
at me because oh all that would be on
his feed is boobs like bro I don't
scroll in that account and the algorithm
it counts your watch time bro so
don't go after me G yeah because he's
probably sitting at the kitchen counter
like looking at his own Tick Tock and
his wife walks by and it's like teenage
girls boobies text Sunny what the [ __ ]
man I'm like I don't I have my own
account I scroll on dude I just post for
you that was funny
yeah you guys are up my ass could be a
technician and cut hair that is
absolutely fine why is everyone up my
ass about driving an A5 we'll explain it
again as we've explained yes Disney
spoke as [ __ ] but that's not the point
it's a 2014 A5 it had 30 000 miles and I
got it for twenty seven thousand dollars
that's a steal he we've talked we've
talked actively about making money and
plus at the time reinvesting it into the
business or investing it in just period
uh personal Investments instead of
blowing it on big flashy things I can
add that I cannot on to that too because
at the time crypto dipped for the first
time so eth hit like below three
thousand twenty five hundred so I was
like all right I'll get this car finance
it and then once crypto rises again I'll
pay it off you weren't looking at
anything much fancier than that anyway
like maybe another 10 grand like it you
weren't looking at anything nuts no it's
a nice car everyone loves it I love
riding around in that thing it's it's my
first car my logic too was I'll get you
know it's like a you know a decent it's
a good car drive that for a year get my
insurance good because I'm eight I was
18 years old you know get my insurance
going and then you know once I have like
some proof of insurance and safe driving
history then I can upgrade to a car
you get so she has a convertible in
addition to her SUV and then you get
exactly right am I wrong no would you
want the car if I'm done with it so it's
paid off you just take the take the whip
it really depends I don't know yeah
assuming all all is yeah it's a cool car
it's lovely and the dog likes it I know
these boys driving cars with no wheels
shown on my car get out of here you
really want to create value create value
for other people they're back in your
careers make them rent chairs for me bro
yeah because you are not going to become
a millionaire giving people Fades yeah
number two in regards to understand
where you are one thing that I have to
give sneako a lot of credit for the
first thing he said to me let me down
and I said I watch your content I really
respect you I'm really glad to meet you
when I was coming up that was something
I feel like I was very very good at and
I have to give you credit for how
respectful and and how straight up
honest you are with everybody in the
space man and I think that's got you a
long way it makes it super easy is like
really good with that [ __ ] he's so shut
up how to put your ego to the side a lot
of people they have a lot of self-esteem
they have a lot of ideas and once they
they take the red pill or they realize
that they want to add value to the world
they immediately assume that they are
valuable instead of adding that and they
they don't know how to separate their
ego so me saying that to you like I
respect you I watch your videos you've
inspired me a lot of people won't put
themselves in that situation because
you'll be the little bro you don't want
to become less than somebody else or you
don't want to feel worthless but you
need to put that you need exactly what
you said you need to realize where you
are on the totem pole I realize where I
am and what value I add you need to be
honest with yourself that's something
that a lot of people aren't able to do
absolutely because of social media I
think it's because of how everybody is
always putting up an image of how
important they are if you let go of that
and stop playing Sims with Instagram
you'll succeed it's also very much a
sign of intelligence
Nico he looks awesome I'm so psyched
he's in Romania he looks cool he's got
it all going on and he's a pumpkin he is
and everything he just said just makes
me want to say he's a sweet pumpkin he's
good he's a good guy I'm a mom I can say
that and I know he gets a little mad
when I call him pumpkin but
um
[Music]
[Music]